El fantasma del cólera ataca de nuevo
agua escasa y contaminada utilizada para
higiene y consumo en un campamento
refugiados sirios en Líbano donde las
condiciones son precarias en solubles
cavar un agujeros en el suelo El inodoro
Va allí el agua que usamos para limpiar
Va allí todo va allí
quizás llega al pozo que usamos para
lavar la ropa
una madre de nueve hijos lucha por
cuidarlos en un duro contexto pero las
carencias dominan el lugar
a veces hay que priorizar le doy más
importancia al agua que a cambiar la
bomba de gas bebemos de allí una vez y a
mi hijo menor bebiendo del Grifo del
agua del pozo ese pozo está
completamente sucio el agua de las
alcantarillas entra ahí
la casa de Fátima tiene graves
inconvenientes sanitarios
primero el sistema de alcantarillado no
sé ni qué decir mira cómo quedó la
cocina por dentro se rompió El inodoro
de la cocina y usé un balde para recoger
todo el balde que uso para lavar y
limpiar
la alerta por el cólera resonó la
Organización Mundial de la Salud pero la
entidad ve una posibilidad de frenar el
brote en el norte libanés
hay que pensar un panorama más amplio
decir que podemos hacer para detener la
transmisión el mensaje es que tenemos
una oportunidad de oro para limitar la
propagación ahora afecta a los
refugiados sirios pero tarde o temprano
aparecerán más casos en libaneses
el gobierno afirma que las
interrupciones de energía eléctrica
impiden el suministro de agua limpia y
esperan por vacunas Aunque la escasez
pone interrogantes sobre cuando las
recibirán tras 30 años el país vuelve a
registrar cólera desde el primer caso a
principios de octubre se produjeron
cinco muertes y hay 220 enfermos